[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
story times je suis à l'aéroport nous
devions partir aujourd'hui non par la
france avec cette magnifique ont paniqué
nommera air france et ils ont pas pensé
vous auriez un petit message pour vous
dire que pour rencontrer vous êtes dans
mon pc chose que j'ai déjà voyagé quatre
fois depuis quatre ans nous avaient pas
besoin et donc rien à un mail
bloqués les emplois jeu depuis trois ans
on doit changer le budget pour pouvoir
essayer de partir l'autre jour on peut
partir d'eau douce qu'on arrive au
week-end nous touchons new yorkais
[Musique]
bon voilà cette vidéo pour dire que j'ai
attaché mon nouveau vélo si vous volez
mon vélo sur la tête de ma petite tortue
ça va mal se passer donc s'il vous plaît
anne hidalgo je voulais qu'on roule en
vélo moi je veux bien on n'arrête pas de
me fourrer mon vélo la jerry un cadenas
donc là tout est prêt là on peut pas me
voler ma si vous me le voler
alors là ça va mal se passer maintenant
[Musique]
châteauroux max anstie
réfrigérateur c'est tout plat toujours
votre favorite face à la chaîne
de vidéo arrive ce soir par les matchs
en direct
de mon salon
go
[Musique]
austères